zwei männer finden die leiche einer
jungen frau und müssen diesen
schrecklichen fund ihrer familie
mitteilen
sie stehen vor der fenster fassade des
hauses der familie und verzögern den
moment der übertragungen nachricht das
ist alles worum es in wismar links
interieur diesem kurzen stück 1895
uraufgeführt in paris geht es ist eine
initial werk der moderne warum weil
alles vom beobachten handelt vom selbst
beobachten und von beobachten der
anderen das schicksal der menschen hängt
an einem fenster
deswegen wollen wir dieses stück über
die metapher des fensters beschreiben
wir wollen das fenster ernst nehmen als
lebens gegenstand von seiner materiellen
technischen seite von der art und weise
wie wir es pflegen wie es behandelt wie
es berühren und auch von der
metaphorischen künstlerischen seite soll
es in dieser folge eine rolle spielen
großvater links interieur durchs fenster
betrachtet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
fenster sind unsere augen zur welt wir
brauchen sie um zu schauen um zu leben
wir stehen hier vor der glaserei
rosenthal seit 20 jahren in berlin
charlottenburg einer der entscheidenden
anlaufpunkte für glas und fenster und
sprechen jetzt gleich mit dem inhaber
andreas rosenthal über die technische
seite des fensters ein fenster besteht
aus holz kunststoff oder metall und ein
fenster ist eigentlich die lichtquelle
oder die belüftungs quelle für einraum
sozusagen was gibt es dafür
unterschiedliche glas wein gibt ganz
normale fenstergläser je nach anspruchs
klasse also sprich welche sagen wir mal
sicherheit effizienz die haben müssen
oder also ganz normale frau gläser bei
ganz normalen wohnungsfenster wird 4 mm
50 mm verwendet und türen oder im
absturz bereich wird dann
sicherheitsglas verwenden mit folien
einlagen oder verschiedene geschichten
drin da gibt es als endlose paletten
wird haben sie dabei spiele viel also
was wir haben zum beispiel ganz normale
struktur dieser die sind nicht
durchsichtig aber man sieht dass man die
silhouetten dahinter sieht für
badfenster oder arztpraxen oder sonst
irgendwie was verwendet
dann haben wir verschiedene motive die
ist dann wieder ein bisschen
durchsichtiger hat aber so etwas so eine
struktur wieso das nennt man muss antik
wie ein bisschen auf alt gemacht für
türen
meistens werde diese sachen soviel
wohnungstüren oder wie gesagt für für
badfenster verwendet hatte
hat sich nicht viel verändert wenn man
jetzt mal gesagt in den letzten 30 40
jahren in der art die fenster gemacht
werden
früher gab es einfach verglasung und
heute gibt es halt eben diese
sogenannten wärmeschutzverordnung seit
95 die stetig natürlich steigen durch
energieeffizienz und da wären halt immer
mehr isoliergläser verwendeten gerade im
neubau die einfachverglasung derzeit
noch in den altbau bereich und die
werden noch wie ursprünglich mit fenster
eingesetzt und heutzutage werden die
entweder mit dem drucker klassen mit
gummis auf leisten gemacht oder mit
silikon teil dem versiegeln
[Musik]
warum soll ich sie baut begleiten gehen
sie doch allein
ich warte bis sie mich rufen ich bin nur
auf der tour ich reiße ich mit ich bin
ein fremder
so etwas macht man besser nicht allein
ein unglück dass man nicht alleine
mitteilt ist weniger eindeutig und
weniger bedrückend dem weg gehe habe ich
darüber nachgedacht
wenn ich allein hineingehe sich gleich
anfangen zu reden
nach ein paar worten wissen sie bescheid
und ich habe nichts mehr zu sagen und
ich habe angst vor dem schweigen das auf
die letzten worte einer unglücks
botschaft folgt dann bricht es einem das
herz wenn wir zusammen hineingehen sage
ich ihnen beispielsweise nach lange
umschweife
man hat sie so gefunden sie trieb auf
dem fluss ihre hände waren gefaltet ihre
hände waren nicht gefallen ihre arme in
längs des körpers sehen sie und wirklich
redet man und die ganzen einzelheiten
denken von dem eigentlichen unglück ab
gehe ich hingegen allein rein wissen sie
es schon bei den ersten worten und ich
sie kennen ihre das schrecklich und gott
weiß was passiert sprechen wir jedoch ab
wechselt dann hören sie uns zu und
denken nicht daran der schlechten
nachricht ins auge zu sehen
[Musik]
erst mal wie lange sind sie denn schon
als reiniger also angefangen zu lernen
habe ich erst 475 seitdem belegt dabei
so 46 jahre
ok und wenn wir jetzt hier mal diese
fenster vor einfach nur beispielhaft was
sind das für fenster das sind
doppelfenster mit oberlicht manche sagen
kastenfenster doppelfenster dann da
drüben zb sind diese kleine oberlichter
da drüben da muss man ein bisschen mehr
arbeiten oder sind kasten für also das
sind kofax da muss man dann richtig
also da ist richtig arbeit hier ist
einfach ist einfach zu jeweils die
durchgehende fläche ist da muss man
einfach schön ledernen krieges nachricht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie geht man jetzt wie gehen sie jetzt
haben also ein fenster ich mich neben
wasser und seife seife was wir sein
projekt ganz normal fit war also es ist
fett lösen sind wichtige und wir
brauchen sie nicht also wenn es jetzt
normal verdreckt ist also sprich
medizinische raucht wird groß oder sogar
auch macht aber speziell auch es läuft
ja ja und da mal früher seien mehr
kilometer bei die meisten leute rauchen
heute auf dem balkon ja
[Musik]
sie selber jetzt ja wie oft sie ihre
fenster zu hause alle sechs wochen alles
verlangt nur eine frau also ich mache
wirklich so alle 4 6 wochen je nachdem
dies regelt aber im schnitt sag ich
immer zweimal im jahr im frühjahr und im
herbst
und dazwischen wenn jemand dreimal
handel oder sowas
geschmackssache also wird sich selber
dabei na klar fenster so was sind das
für sie persönlich so als gegenstände
ich meine sie haben ja bestimmt eine
besondere beziehung naja sagen wir mal
so ich gucke ob in oder sonst irgendwo
egal wo ich gucke immer auf die fenster
meine frau ist floristin die kommt immer
auf die blumen macht jeder irgendwo ja
ich gucke dann einfach nur sind die
fenster sauber einfach jetzt nicht dass
ich bestimmte schweren oder sogar das
nicht oder putzen ist aber wie einfach
nur wieso wir kennen zwar ebenso
aussehen war mit meiner tochter von paar
jahren in new york die hatten alle
dritte fenster also war ich echt
erschrocken
sie sehen anhand der schätzer mitunter
als meine also jetzt nur meine erfahrung
anhand mitunter der fenster wie die
küche im restaurant aussieht manchmal
sah so aus wie ich werde jetzt zum
beispiel ein sturm war dann ist klar
dass die fenster von außen
diese innen drin sind dann wird klar
eingehen kann
das revolutionäre das was dieses stück
interieur zu einem initial werk der
moderne gemacht hat sind vor allem auch
die bühnen anweisungen da heißt es ganz
zu anfang etwa ein alter garten in dem
weiden stehen im hintergrund ein haus
drei fenster im erdgeschoss sind
erleuchtet recht deutlich erkennt man im
schein der lampe eine familie beim
abendlichen zusammensein
lichtverhältnisse entfernung und ein
leichter beschlag auf den scheiben
lassen alle bewegungen wie vergeistigt
erscheinen
man merkt hier sofort dass es in diesem
stück nicht nur um die handlung nicht
nur um die dialoge geht sondern dass
lichtverhältnisse und die bühne eine
zentrale rolle spielen die drei fenster
symbolisieren wenn man so will auf der
einen seite den schutz der familie drin
vor den schrecken der wirklichkeit und
auf der anderen seite die einzige chance
für die zwei männer draußen auf
intimität auf eine in beziehung name mit
den menschen drin in dieser weise sind
sie eine doppel 5 haben sie eine
doppelfunktion sie sind schutzschild und
hoffnungsträger in einem symbolisieren
wenn man so will in der müde gewordenen
moderne den letzten rest an transzendenz
an chance auf über wirklichkeit und was
uns mailings stück in einer gewissen
weise eben dadurch auch lehrt ist dass
wir die fenster unsere fenster nicht
einfach nur als gebrauchsgegenstände
anschauen sollen sondern sie auch ernst
nehmen in ihrer metaphorischen bedeutung
als unsere schützenden augen zur welt
[Musik]
möglicherweise ist ihr tod man weiß
nicht was weiß man denn schon vielleicht
gehörte sie zu denen die nicht sagen
wollen ohnehin blickt jeder mehr als
einen grund in sich nicht mehr leben zu
wollen
in eine seele kann man nicht wie in
dieses zimmer sehen
alle sind sie so sie sagen nur
oberflächliche dinge und niemand ahnt
etwas monate lang lebt man neben einem
der nicht mehr von dieser welt ist für
dessen seele ist keine umkehr gibt man
antwortet ihm ahnungslos und sie sehen
was passiert die unbewegliche puppen
sehen sie aus und so viele ereignisse
finden in ihren sälen statt
sie wissen selbst nicht was sie sind
sie hätten gelebt wie die anderen leben
man muss dem gewöhnlichen leben etwas
hinzufügen um es verstehen zu koennen
man geht seite an seite lässt sich nicht
aus den augen und nimmt sich erst in dem
moment war wo man für immer fort geht
[Musik]
[Applaus]